I
didn't know much about the real problems
in the country.
I'd say that,
I mean there are problems of race that
we hardly knew existed in San Francisco,
but they were right in front of us and
gradually got to see what they were.
I can remember my mother telling me one
day she had a friend who was black and
they wanted to go to a restaurant for
lunch and they were going to go to the
St Francis Hotel and they were
discussing whether they could.
And that was San Francisco.
That wasn't the south.
There is not a magic answer.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I'm probably since I recently wrote it
to sand in the,
in the,
uh,
in,
in a case involving
the use of race conscious criteria in
schools.
That is whether the city of Seattle
could use a,
a,
as one criteria among several.
They allowed high school students
freedom to choose whatever school they
wanted.
They listed preferences,
but they said that no school will be
more than 85 percent white.
Basically that was their criteria.
And the question was,
could they actually overtly in that way
use a racial criteria and the court five
to four,
uh,
decided that they could not,
they could not.
I descended,
I thought,
of course I can at work consequences
relevant there.
They certainly were to me,
as I said,
if you interpret the equal protection
clause to,
uh,
into,
for bid,
this is how are people supposed to deal
with problems of race and poverty in the
inner cities of America.
And I see the constitution as a very
workable document.
I think Madison's genius was to say
we're going to get these values will
stay the same and we're going to embody
them in words that allow their
application over the course of the next
four or 500 years and if not,
if not longer.
And to do that,
you have to refer back to how do these
values apply today?
What's the value of the equal protection
clause?
Trying to bring us together,
trying to create one nation,
trying to create races that were
separate indeed one held in slavery like
a caste system and try to create one
country out of this diversity and it's a
miracle.
But we've been able to do that to a
degree.
There's still plenty of problems.
And for me to think of that clause being
posed as an obstacle to such an effort.
Uh,
well I just think that that was wrong.
And I expressed my views very concisely
in about 77 pages.
I'm basically optimistic even with the
thing I was most pessimistic about,
to go back to read a specific case.
I W I was most pessimistic about the
court's decision in the Seattle case
involving the use of race conscious
criteria.
I think about that seriously.
I was in a descent.
I think it's a bad decision.
That's what I wrote.
Uh,
the,
uh,
impedes the ability of
communities to,
uh,
take people who were isolated in the
center of the city,
very poor family background could be
terrible and,
uh,
lacking opportunity and try to work out
the problems in the,
in the,
in the community context.
So I think this is a bad decision.
It's a throwback,
but it's only a throwback to see because
really,
ultimately I am an optimist.
And ultimately I do think that people
overcome even this kind of a barrier and
people figure out how to solve these
problems.
Not perfectly,
but we'll do it.
The country itself is becoming much more
of a diverse country and yet we will
cooperate.
We cooperate,
we know how to do it.
That's really,
I think are,
are great.
Uh,
uh,
if there's an American contribution,
I think it's in that respect,
the respect of being open and coming
into a problem and not being prejudiced
about it and trying to look for whatever
solution arises out of the problem.
It's a pragmatic attitude.
It's an attitude that is not a respecter
of persons.
It's a respecter of problems and we
don't just take what people say
for me.